did you know that the body mass index is
racist
BMI
which is one of the ways that we measure
obesity
that is now racist according to the
American Medical Association which is
the largest Council of doctors in the
United States they're going to say
goodbye to it because BMI they say as
racist Roots the report from the AMA
says that quote BMI does not
appropriately represent racial and
ethnic minorities because it's based on
the imagined ideal Caucasian of the 19th
century without considering a person's
gender or ethnicity
so the reason that they're saying it's
racist is because
black women in particular are very obese
as a group they are the most obese group
of anybody this became a political
talking point during covid because
people who were more obese were more
likely to suffer complications from
kovid and so the lib said that covet is
racist but coveted obviously is not
racist there are just certain unhealthy
behaviors and conditions that are more
associated with black people than with
white people and specifically black
women than other people and so they say
it's all racist and it's all because of
white supremacy because everything has
to be white people's fault so the AMA
goes on they say South Asians in
particular have especially high levels
of body fat and are more prone to
developing abdominal obesity than whites
which may account for their very high
risk of type 2 diabetes and
cardiovascular disease in contrast some
Studies have found that blacks have
lower body fat and higher lean muscle
mass than whites at the same BMI and
therefore may be at lower risk of
obesity related diseases notice they
don't compare bmis of the different
groups they're just saying at the same
BMI here's muscle to fat and of course
that's true different peoples are
different obviously I'm a little swarthy
here my ancestors come from Southern
Italy and at least on one side of my
family and so yeah my skin is going to
be a little darker than people from
Scandinavia it's going to be a little
lighter than people from Nigeria my hair
is going to be a little bit different
than the hair of people from all over
the world and so sure it naturally
follows that all sorts of aspects of my
body are going to be different from
other peoples
does that mean that body mass index is
no longer useful
no of course not that's a complete
non-sequitur
does that mean that BMI is a racist
no of course not but
racism as we've observed on the show
before and is becoming increasingly
clear in our culture
racist just means White
if a thing is white if a thing has
connection to white people if a thing is
more closely associated with
white people than non-white people it is
racist in our modern culture white just
means bad
so because BMI was developed by white
people
on white people using experiments that
involved white people it's just bad
because America
historically was a white country America
is bad because Europe is the continent
of the white people
then Europe is bad and
those places will be blamed for things
that take place in Asia that take place
in South Asia that take place in Africa
they take place in Pacific Islands
slavery cannibalism even cannibalism
which wasn't actually practiced in the
west and the word comes from the
indigenous peoples of the Americas and
specifically from the Carib Islanders
doesn't matter there'll be anything
anything
that has existed everywhere it's bad
when white people do it it's not bad
when other people do it and that's that
and you can try to make sense of it and
you can bang your head against one say
wait a second this is so crazy these
lips have gone too far how on Earth
could you say that that ways to protect
the health specifically the health of
black people could ever be racist it
doesn't come on the logic it's not
logical you you have to recognize that
the libs are beginning with the
conclusion the conclusion is white
people are bad
okay white people they're the only group
for whom you against whom you can
legally discriminate and socially
discriminate
Asians you can also legally discriminate
against in college admissions and
employment but and really specifically
College admissions affirmative action
but
white people are the only group where
you not only can legally discriminate
against them but it is socially
acceptable and encouraged to insult them
to discriminate against them socially to
ostracize them it's the only group so
that's the conclusion and you're going
to fill in all the the Absurd background
such that you've got the American
Medical Association saying oh obesity is
great obesity is great if you lose
weight you're racist and you see this in
the body positivity movement and the the
now worship of a pop singer like lizzo
if anyone suggests that maybe lizzo
ought to get a little bit more healthy
that that would be good for her that's
considered racist
if you liked the sound of that you are
going to love the taste of magic spoon
even more with magic spoon you can say
goodbye to Bland sugary cereals and
experience breakfast like never before
packed with high quality ingredients and
flavors that you already know and love
like cocoa fruity frosted and peanut
butter which is very very tasty magic
spoon will take your breakfast game to
new heights my producer Ben Davies can't
stop talking about how much he loves
magic spoons peanut butter cereal
to which I say hey you jerk stop
stealing the peanut butter cereal from
the office and let me have it instead
but he loves it he really likes it so I
I figure I'll throw the guy a bone he
can have the box of peanut butter I'll
save myself for the other side magic
spoon cereals have zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and are only
140 calories per serving they're also
gluten-free grain free and soy free
experience the magic of magic spoon
cereals by visiting magicspoon.com
Knolls and get five bucks off your order
Magic spoon is so confident in their
product they back it with a 100
happiness guarantee if you don't like it
for any reason they will refund your
money what are you waiting for click the
link below or head over to
magicspoon.com Knowles to grab a variety
pack try it today magicspoon.com Knowles
for five bucks off your order
speaking of racial issues
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis number two
guy in the Republican race for president
has a new border plan
the crisis at the southern border a
record 2.76 million migrants crossed the
border during the 2022 fiscal year
shattering the previous annual record by
more than one million I'm not old enough
to walk but have already traveled
hundreds of miles
[Music]
and less safe here we go we see all the
numbers
127 terrorists apprehended trying to
cross the border so true
we will secure the Border
towels
like that he's using the word Invasion
that's very strong no excuses okay
the plan might be good the commercial's
weak and the commercial's weak because
the commercial doesn't include specifics
and because the commercial is diagnosing
the problem recognizing the problem but
not getting specific on the solutions
other than all the stuff that
Republicans have been talking about for
a long time that they haven't really
done
Trump had a real Advantage here in 2016
because he offered new Solutions
we're going to build the wall we're
going to deport all these people we're
go we're going to end Birthright
citizenship okay great wow that was new
that sounded exciting people voted for
him on that
premise but then he didn't really do it
he built some of the wall
illegal immigration dropped in the first
months of the presidency but then the
illegal immigrants and the cartels
realized that the law wasn't really
going to be enforced maybe that was
Trump's fault maybe it wasn't Trump's
fault maybe Trump just couldn't wield
the bureaucracy effectively enough
regardless
illegal immigration jumped right back up
so
now the the idea of building the wall or
whatever even that is not novel
people need more specifics and and we
need to believe that you can actually
get it done now in his speeches Governor
DeSantis has been more specific and he's
talked about how he intends to wield the
levers of power which is good I mean
that's that's a big Improvement I wish
that that sort of thing were in the
campaign commercial this commercial
doesn't really do anything for me I'd
rather just see DeSantis explaining
Nitty Gritty detail what he's going to
do because nobody really believes that
it's going to get done I don't think
anybody really believes that Trump is
going to get it done I don't think
anybody believes that DeSantis or any of
these other candidates are going to get
it done no matter how much they want to
because the the feeling is that even if
a president is totally sincere about
stopping illegal immigration that the
Deep state is going to is going to cut
them off at the knees
that it's going to be held up in court
that's going to be held up by the
executive agencies and that all that
time the borders are going to remain
open and the illegal immigrants are
going to come over to the tune of three
and a half million per year
you know it's it's not totally fair to
attack DeSantis for this because
the reason that
he needs to get so specific the reason
he doesn't really have credibility here
is in part because even Trump failed to
do it even Trump who is the most
anti-immigration president for president
presidential candidate for a major party
in my lifetime even he couldn't get the
job done
so now I wonder if immigration is even
going to be a big issue in 2024 I think
a lot of Republicans have just written
it off just said yeah
we tried there's really no solution on
the horizon we've got to focus our
attention
elsewhere I'm so glad you liked that
clip wasn't it great I loved it make
sure you subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel make sure you
ring that Bell to get all the other
clips and interviews and games and
episodes